hey wisecrack flesh Jared again before
we get into it just a note we didn't do
a quick take last week because well
while the world leader Lee conspiracy
was one of our favorite episodes of the
season we didn't really have much to add
to the discussion but we're back to take
on season 3 episode 6 where we'll be
looking at the toxic side of our
favorite adventuring duo I really love
this episode for two reasons first they
managed to address the kind of character
development we crave in a way that's
both satisfying and the exact opposite
of what regular TV does and second
things happen to some really interesting
ideas about mental health so fire your
therapist and join me on this quick take
of rest and relaxation a quick recap
Rick and Morty need a break from almost
dying all the time this was insane that
was pure luck I was not in control of
that situation at all and come to the
realization that there burned out so
they vacation at an alien spa and take a
mental detoxifier for a spin
while the duo feel cleansed and
rejuvenated they leave behind the parts
they hate most about themselves morty
continues to live his life without the
sense of crippling self-doubt becomes
the most popular kid in school and even
lands a date with Jessica meanwhile Rick
seems like a normal human being
excuse me but this new reality is
interrupted as the toxic versions of
themselves managed to escape and turn
the whole world weird as we praise our
loving father we may one of the
cleverest aspects of this episode is
what I'm going to call anti character
development as we've mentioned before
Dan Harmon is a strict adherent to his
version of Joseph Campbell's the hero's
journey
now the relevant part here is that many
stories use protagonist confronting
their shadow a kind of dark reflection
of themselves that they must overcome
like dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde in terms of
character development this overcoming
usually means our hero has some new
insight on life like when a compassion
and Logan's sacrifices himself battling
the murderous x.25
overcoming his selfishness or when luke
skywalker's spares darth vader
overcoming his temptation toward the
darkside this episode uses this
structure toxic morty and toxic rick are
quite literal shadow versions of
themselves but instead of overcoming
their toxic personality traits this
episode is a journey to reunite with
their worst selves excuse me
healthy Morty is a smooth operator with
lots of friends who ultimately needs to
rediscover his self-loathing and healthy
Rick is a thoughtful super genius who
needs to rediscover his narcissism and
irrational care for Morty if anything
the regular kind of character
development normally I would come down
on any kind of disruption but it seems
to represent a positive change for your
character is pretty creepy but I also
think this anti character development
serves as a pretty smart commentary on
Mental Health in our society rest and
relaxation asks what does it mean to be
mentally healthy word around school is
you've become super healthy in many ways
this episode serves as an extended
parody of certain healthy attitudes
promoted by self-help gurus popular
media and the occasional life purpose
cheerleader I swear they exist in elect
focus on the good things trust me
things are good in particular this idea
that we must strive to eliminate any
thoughts that are unpleasant or painful
hashtag positive vibes hashtag self-care
hashtag blessed hashtag sorry not sorry
now there are a ton of insta lections
will tell you that being mentally
healthy means uncritically loving
yourself saying yes to everything
counting your blessings and believing in
yourself no matter how stupid your
passive income scheme is however Rick
and Morty shows us that these ideals
fully embodied will make you seem like a
coked-out weirdo you know you're so
quiet what's wrong tell me about
yourself what's the atmosphere like on
planet Jessica I think one of the ideas
the show is getting at is something
sociologist William Davies has written
about in his book in the happiness
industry for our longtime fans we
actually talked about this book in our
inside out video Davies writes about a
concept he calls compulsory happiness
that in our modern world there exists a
kind of alliance between corporations
managers and advertisers to promote a
definition of mental health that
ultimately
serves the capitalist society that we
live in a kind of happiness that
involves cheerfully accepting the status
quo something touched on by Rick before
because I don't respect therapy I think
it's helped a lot of people get
comfortable and stop panicking
which is a state of mind we value in the
animals who eat this kind of happiness
also requires constant self-improvement
for the sake of being a better consumer
let's work off your trauma with some
urban spin yoga it's amazing you do yoga
on a bike but you have an at-risk
preteen I don't think I could just blow
this off Morty we see Morty spouting
platitudes that seem lifted from a Tony
Robbins book I love drum lessons why
limitations we are addicted to our own
limitations how amazing is that
demanding that everyone around him
partake in his new lifestyle you have to
do this detox thing I did it's at an
alien spa you go through it
ocean when confronted with real-life
problems like a sentient part of himself
being trapped in hell his answer is
trust me
things are good taking that away from me
that wouldn't be healthy the problem
with this is that many of the things the
self-help industry wants you to erase
like self-doubt and sadness are pretty
important in the case of Morty it can
hold you back from becoming a full-on
sociopath and a sociopath he becomes in
a scene lifted from the wolf of Wall
Street
it looks like healthy Morty is at the
top of his game as an unscrupulous
stockbroker Hein holds biotech
million-and-a-half at 33 with a new hot
redhead to replace Jessica Rick even
compares him to another sociopathic Wall
Street fat cat with too much self-esteem
so what about Rick Rick realizes some of
these less desirable parts of ourselves
despite the pain they caused are
essential to actually being healthy
Morty do the healthy thing and
voluntarily retox off' i yourself
jessica even tells morty get to have you
back suggesting that Morty's authentic
self-hating self is truly his better
self but my only complaint with this
episode is well it doesn't really make
sense we're meant to believe that the
undesirable parts of a person are purged
from their being based on their own
subjective definition of toxicity how
could that dee talk to machine know the
difference between healthy and sick for
everything that goes through it it can't
it must be by the individual's own
definition of
toxicity yet healthy Rick says this to
Morty I'm real proud to be your grandpa
morning then later claims that his
attachment to Morty is irrational
therefore toxic and allows him to
nonchalantly do this so is his love for
more detoxic or healthy well for more
thoughts on that be sure to check out
the squanch our very own Rick and Morty
podcast we've been breaking down every
episode of Rick and Morty and people
seem to like it
for those of you missing a quick take on
the were literally conspiracy we've even
got an episode on that you can find a
link in the description or almost
anywhere you get your podcasts iTunes
stitcher Google Play SoundCloud just to
name a few and don't forget to leave a
review on iTunes we might even read it
on air thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]